hello there it's been over a month since
the fortnite island had an update and
finally it looks like the story is about
to kick back into Life The Narrative has
been narrowed down from an Intergalactic
multiversal War now it's just a man
looking for his banana yeah there's no
way to say that in a cool way
sorry but this is fortnite if we scratch
the surface a much deeper plot is coming
and the inevitable return of Midas I'm
adamaru let's break down fortnite's new
Direction epic games have been leaving
hints about midas's return since the
very day the chapter began but it wasn't
until I saw a picture of the device
midas's device in Valeria's book that I
was certain of it first midas's yacht
the marold was added to the chapter the
black white and gold ship had one key
change his statue was replaced by a logo
of the society one of the feuding
factions this season maybe that was a
coincidence right then we noticed
midas's golden doors at the hotel
previously seen in the chapter 2 season
2 trailer which introduced Midas and his
crew that could have been just a reused
asset but the references keep coming a
small island off the coast was found
strewn with Midas memorabilia from his
agency painting to the helmet of one of
his guards to meow's cotton ball and
even the pin board used by Sky not
enough more evidence needed fine three
beach houses can be found once again
claimed by midas's old crew with sky and
mowles person izing their own
place and then finally midas's chair the
very same one he used to begin the
device event all those years ago in
Chapter 2 is hidden away
here Midas was a double agent working
for Io and himself he created a device
to push back the Battle Royale storm it
also allowed us to leave the loop and
thanks to that we spoke to agent Jones
for the very first time what the how are
you even
wait wait wait wait can you can you hear
me hear me hear me whilst there we could
see M's case file on Jon Jones's desk
and fast forward back to this season the
very same file is hiding in plain sight
in the season trailer on the ground in
the underground space I think it's safe
to say Midas is coming back but how will
he fit into the story let's recap what
we know so
far for the first six years of Battle
Royale everything was focused on one
thing the zero point the center of
reality and the link between all other
worlds the plot was simple the zero
point needed freeing so that's what we
did yet every time our success was
shortlived as another enemy appeared
that cycle was finally broken when our
longtime hero agent Jones and his best
friend and worst enemy Dr Sloan forgave
each other and worked together to break
free of that plotline the zero point is
seemingly no more the shackles of
reality are gone and a new World arrived
with the zero point out of commission
Jonesy is unwittingly the man with the
most knowledge and arguably the most
power on the island you know as he's
hundreds of years old and according to
the comic books he was given immortality
by jeno this makes him and everyone
around him a Target and that's likely
why his best mate peely has been taken
armed with his manly stubble new attire
and lots of guns Jones will stop at
nothing to find his friend
Jones Is Now part of a new faction also
known as The Underground a resistance
group standing against the main villains
of the chapter the society that group
has much more wealth Manpower and
weaponry to influence the island and
control it with force and an epic games
blog can confirm this the society is
pulling the strings in secret and
they've taken peely in their spite join
the underground and take down the
society's bosses including its most
notorious boss Valaria as with most
fortnite seasons the characters are more
important than their factions take a
look at Valaria and hope these two are
related one is the boss of the society
and the other is the leader of the
underground and they are sisters let's
break down those factions first the
underground hope began this group to
stand against the wealthy socialites
that control the island although
official in nature they remain in the
shadows setting up literally in the
underground away from Prim in eyes with
little funding the underground are
constantly falling behind the advances
the society make hope and Jon Jones are
working together yet it's not a full
Alliance a deal has been done hope will
assist Jones in finding peely in return
for Jones running missions to disrupt
the society and Supply Intel this
agreement suits both parties for the
time being at least as each time we get
close to pe's location we're already too
late and only a banana calling card is
Left Behind
on the other side is the society a
larger than life faction built on Power
and money so much money we know Valeria
is the boss here but another member
monague seems to be the originator of
the society's Vision the loading screen
for montigue States I present my vision
for the Island's future the society it
appears that the other members liked
this concept and that birthed the
society another strange thing to note
about monu he possesses A Relic that can
literally turn him into diamonds I'm not
sure if that's important or if it's just
a flex on his friends but he sure can do
it other members of the society include
Oscar and Nisha Oscar is the brawn of
the group a professional Hunter who is
sent in physically to fix any issues the
group have which also lines up with his
loading screen it looks like Oscar is
the one that took peely whereas Nisha
runs a quiet Vineyard on the island and
is a professional fencer okay I have no
idea what her purpose is at all and then
we have valyria the leader with a thirst
for knowledge and another member with a
powerful amulet so big in fact it's a
back bling this one seems to gift her
those Firebrand abilities just like
montue but less shiny in her room and
loading screen we see a whole library of
books but one is placed open for all to
see she's researching some sort of
ancient treasure could this be the
drawing that inspired midas's
stormchaser device back in Chapter 2 and
of course every time we see a chest like
this the fable of Pandora's Box comes up
a treasure when opened that is actually
a curse hey didn't the leakers say next
season is inspired by Greek myth maybe
we're on to something
here so hope is devoted to taking down
the society by any means necessary but
inevitably she will struggle to face her
own sibling she still holds hope that
her relationship with her sister can be
saved whereas Valeria's motivations are
more Sinister a burning ambition for
knowledge and power leads to a
dedication that cannot be stopped the
underground versus the society is the
second level to this chapter's story but
wait there's more Jones can be found in
the underground's main base of operation
looking over the leaders of the society
Crossing them off as they are defeated
but the eagle eyed also noticed
something else down here Jones is
actively searching for peely which makes
sense of course he's been kidnapped but
also Sloan it's unclear if anyone
retained their memories from the live
event but if they did it's likely Jonesy
he still holds out hope that he can one
day find Sloan again in this new world
and if he does retain all his memories
centuries of the stuff then we should
expect Valeria and the society to want
him on their side as a friend or a
prisoner that still leaves us with the
question of Midas how does he fit in I
reckon Valeria's obsession with
knowledge and power will be the link
right now the society are rolling out
excavation Crews to one Earth something
underneath our feet and as leakers tell
us next season is dedicated to Greek
mythology what better time could there
be to find Midas or the very myth he's
based upon I'll leave you with the
society's logo it certainly looks like
Midas is golden hands around his eye
could monu's vision and Valeria's
research lead back to Midas all the
signs are here but hey let's not get
ahead of ourselves right now peely needs
our help and we must locate him before
the end of the the season and that one
act will trigger years of fortnite
storyline I'm Adam you're awesome it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next
time